device installers fans Rejoice he's
finally back after resigning to his
former org back in October device has
just played in his first two games after
almost a year-long Hiatus the question
is how did he do
[Music]
now if you haven't noticed on these
donaties yet the majority of my wardrobe
consists of mostly hoodies and
sweatshirts and if you're like me then
you're in luck because the score Esports
makes both we got our minimalist Esports
crew neck along with our touchgrass
hoodie that might I add now comes in two
new beautiful colorways so if you are
interested then follow the link in the
description to our store website and
check our stuff out okay so in case you
missed everyone and their mother
tweeting about it device is officially
back playing CS go but to understand why
this is important I'll need to give you
a quick rundown device played for
astralis for years and they won four
majors together along with countless
other trophies but in the online era the
team began to stagnate causing device
and some other players to leave in
search of greener pastures however nip
didn't end up being device's Dream Team
after less than six months with them he
ended up putting himself on medical
leave while struggling with mental
health but after nearly a year of radio
silence and thus a metric ton of
rumors device finally announced on
October 27th that he was coming back to
astralis and just this week we got to
see device back in action at the
beautifully titled champion of champions
tour North Europe series 2.
playoffs but there is one giant question
mark heading into the first map device
hadn't played professionally in all of
2022. did he still have that dog in him
well folks I am happy to report that he
most definitely still does six rounds on
T but they uh they do have the comfort
of CT coming up next oh that's nice but
look at the time of ready they're gonna
have to act now otherwise it's gonna be
hard
very much like what tricked it to them
last round that's going to throw that
smoke to funnel them out fully blind
divided to die cover him device with the
deagle spam goes away and he will secure
four kills in this round astralis
defeated tricked in a pretty convincing
2-0 and device he was at the top of the
leaderboard with a 1.66 hltv rating and
a whopping 56 frags but even more
notably device just looked confident he
was taking opening duels played
aggressive positions and to top it all
off his aim looked pretty crispy suffice
it to say he didn't look like someone
who's only been grinding face it for the
last year but that's not all glaive
who's been struggling recently finally
looked back on form
etching his way towards the edge of
Apartments is spotted by Clay he plays
anti-flashies
be a 2K this radar from glaive is lovely
not the cleanest but it gets the jobs on
regardless sees the barrel of the orb as
well and carry those standing around and
the thing massive there from Glam as the
vice chokes in for a double clave was
once the greatest igl in the world so
some people were even suggesting that
maybe he needed his opting brother back
to do what he does best now with all
that being said this was against tricked
no offense to them whatsoever they
played very well but they're not exactly
the most well-known team but astralis's
next match was against heat the French
roster that now boasts Jack's body and
afro this was obviously going to be the
bigger test for the reunited astralis
and unfortunately things didn't go all
too well even with having a lead on each
map they absolutely fumbled it resulting
in overtime losses on both now given a
lot of time for Claire to get into
position body
has been spotted reposition comes in but
Glade ties him down even lower just toy
him with him playing with the idea but a
big head shot now in the 1v1 What's
Happening Now despite the less than
ideal outcome device still kind of
popped off his rating was 1.27 and he
got 69 kills across both Maps so I think
it's completely fair to assume at the
very least that device is still pretty
good at CS go but now he needs blame to
hold for his short device can go for
even more picks up afterwards the awp
blame is going to be forced off the
angle device surely goes down no he
actually turns around towards short
picks up another one there's just gonna
continue walking into him the smoke is
gonna win him some more cover and
devices back baby gets a third blame is
gonna help him out for the final one
astralis get on to eight now
unfortunately for glaive he did not fare
too well against heat so the verdict is
still out on that previous hypothesis I
mentioned but at the end of the day
these were just two matches against
lower tier teams plus they didn't have
config in the lineup so we're playing
with a stand-in from the academy
unfortunately for us this was likely the
last tournament for so we're just gonna
have to wait till next year to see what
else happens but that's also why I think
it's relevant to talk about these two
seemingly small matches we haven't seen
this guy play in a goddamn year so I'm
pretty hyped to see what he can do in
morning sir
rough I enjoy mornings mornings just
don't enjoy me I like mornings like I'm
not like upset I just my brain is not
working you know people make fun of me
for the way I say both because the score
makes both makes both on both both on
both it's disrespectful